hi again everybody thank you so much for
joining us today welcome to the r studio
enterprise community meetup
i'm rachel calling in from boston today
i will be heading to nashville for my
birthday i'm super excited heading there
later today
but i'm joined by my colleague lou who's
going to be helping out in the chat a
bit if anybody has questions there
but if you've just joined now feel free
to introduce yourselves through the chat
window too and say hello
maybe where you're calling in from
i do want to also make note that if you
want to turn on live transcription
during the meetup you can do so as well
in the zoom bar below you just press the
more button
but to go through
a brief agenda
um we will go through some short
introductions of this meetup group
and kelly will introduce us to tips for
navigating internal processes and
advocating for data science
infrastructure
while also sharing her own experience in
doing so
and so hopefully that will
be able to help a few of you also do the
same we're doing things a little bit
differently here today so after kelly's
presentation
we'll stop the recording
and would love to open it up to
discussion with everyone here
to hear what you're facing and how we
can all help each other too
so for anyone joining this group
for the first time a special welcome to
you
this is a friendly and open meetup
environment for teams to share the work
they're doing within their organizations
teach lessons learn
network with each other and really just
allow us to all learn from each other
so thank you all so much for making this
a welcoming community
we really want to create spaces where
everybody can participate and we can
hear from everyone so i like to
reiterate that that
we really love to hear from everyone no
matter your level of experience or the
industry that you work in
so four
questions from the meetup
you can always ask questions in the zoom
chat or raise your hand to ask live but
we also have a slido link that you can
use so you can ask questions anonymously
as well
and if you ever have suggestions or
general feedback please let me know i'll
share a few links in the chat
but if you do find this format helpful
today we'd love to have more champion
chats so i'll start by saying the third
monday of every month we will try to to
stick to that but i'll share more info
when i put the recording up as well
but with all of that thank you again so
much for joining us i'd love to turn it
over to our speaker today kelly o'brien
kelly is a product manager here at our
studio
and is interested in configuration and
workflow management with a passion for r
and data science
thank you colleen
yeah
i'm honored to uh kick off the first
champions chat here then
i just have a couple of slides put
together to hopefully spark some
discussion later on and
apologize up top that my voice is a
little
uh terrible because i did like three
days of hard gravel writing over the
weekend
as
my fun vacation
and uh and i am suffering now but uh
happy to be here talking about
analytic infrastructure which
i have been passionate about for a long
time
before i was a product manager here at
our studio i worked on a solutions
engineering team and that's how i joined
our studio and i see we have i think a
couple solutions engineers on the call
goggin i saw on the call and
and we've got nick from um customer
success uh worked with him for a long
time here at our studio and and rachel
of course
our
ultimate champion of
champions and so happy to to share some
of the experience that
i've gained here at our studio and that
brought me to our studio actually so
um
and
i'm gonna talk a little bit about what
advocating for analytic infrastructure
sort of looks like to me and in my past
lives
and i want to talk about what it is and
why it matters and
ideas for identifying leverage points
for yourself
so that you can be a better advocate for
your own workflows internally at your
own organizations and so that you know
how to interact with the community and
ask for the support that you need from
us and from the community at large so
before i get into that i want to start
by
acknowledging or identifying like where
you are now on the spectrum inside of
your own organization
and uh
and this this slide is it it can be a
little bit depressing so i promise it
will like
we'll have some more optimism from here
but everybody
starts inside of an organization that's
like at a different stage and it's
like organizational culture it's growth
it's points and and there
you know it's important to to identify
where you are on this spectrum of
organizational culture typology because
you need to know what you're sort of
working against
when it comes to
doing advocacy and
asking for change inside of your
organization so
on the right hand side you have your
generative performance orientated
organizations this is the idea like if
you are in this type of organization
like
hopefully you feel really supported and
you can ask for what you need and you
can build business cases to support
those asks
and
everybody is cooperating
building bridges between teams is highly
encouraged you can take risks and feel
supported in that
area
you can fail and then ask questions
about what happened
and you
are
through all of that process sort of
taken care of
in the center you've got your rule
oriented organizations these are more
bureaucratic and there's some
cooperation but not like
super
highly motivated cooperation
you're sort of like
ignored or like bridges are tolerated
but they're not encouraged also
like
novel problem solving
can work over time but you have to work
really hard at it maybe you have to
build some new rules along the way or
show why the old rules
are outdated and it's a lot of work to
get
things done on the left hand side you've
got your pathological organizations
which is
a funny word um
and but i've definitely been a part of
these places where
they are
entirely power oriented there's very
little cooperation
you don't want to stick your head up or
offer new solutions because you'll be
shot down
everybody is shirking their
responsibilities
everybody is scapegoating
and all
novel ideas are crushed and this is a
real soul [ __ ] place to be in and if
you are in this place like i
i'm very sorry
i hope that you'll find some support
within this group as well because um you
know like
that you can find yourself inside of
these places and teams and and it's
really unfortunate and we want to help
you understand and see from the outside
that
it it's really
almost impossible to make change and
advocate for yourself if you are truly
inside of a pathological organization
we want to see you move towards a
healthier spaces where you can't find
more cooperation and support so
i just lay this out at the beginning of
every time i give sort of one of these
talks because i know everybody's coming
from
different types
of organizations and spaces
and uh and i don't want to paint this as
like a super rosy picture where
like you can do everything because
because sometimes there are just forces
at play that are really difficult to
navigate and move against and and so
um yeah i'll leave it at that and we'll
we'll now go into the more optimism side
of the story so i i hope that
um you know
as you're looking at yourself in this
picture you're finding yourself more on
the right hand from the left-hand side
but if you are more on the left-hand
side then then just know that this is a
safe space we're here to talk about it
so what is analytic infrastructure
i define it as
all the how where
and with what that goes into doing your
daily data science work this is sort of
a picture of a bunch of stuff that could
uh
involve
portions of your analytic infrastructure
environment ignore the red line and the
box in the center it's
just sort of in there from a different
diagram but you've got data sources
you've got processes you've got
artifacts that you're building you're
deploying managing scaling those
artifacts that you've built off of
processes that involve data sources and
you could be integrating with other
things like bi databases reporting
systems workflows
underneath you've got like security and
control access validation
and then other things programming
languages packages and dependencies and
operating systems all of these things
play into
how you do your daily data science work
and all of these things look different
in
different organizations they'll look
different for you like we use the terms
like levels of sophistication but even
that is like a little bit
i don't know
hard to put into a box like when i have
polled previously
groups of our users about what their
definition of production is here are
some of like the
varied answers i've gotten to that
question
production could be
doing things at scale
it could be things that are customer or
user facing it could be like something
as technical as like
production is a service level agreement
they are for mission-critical operations
um it could just be a set of environment
requirements like areas where
validated applications are deployed in a
lockdown way
it could be that production means just
documenting processes
doing due diligence around testing and
monitoring
my favorite answer is in the middle
somebody just wrote a single word
response credibility which is pretty
great
um and and so you can see there's like
all of these different things that go
into production production
to me is like how you define
the environment across the board
from
even starting with development all the
way to whatever it ends up being that
you deliver and
and those environments that you're doing
your work inside of
um i don't
i don't want people to get caught up in
the hype machine here like this is
a screenshot of me googling devops tools
and like
little
crazy sets of like
like
tools that you could employ to build out
these environments and i want to say
like that i'm not going to
provide any solutions here like
our studio sales products but you can
build environments completely on
open source tools like we're not here to
give you any like
easy answers even because there are none
there is no standard architecture
because
you know the types of problems that you
are trying to solve and so you need to
understand like
what tools make sense for you
in your own environment and and there's
also no perfect deployment pipeline
everything
is and should be
evolving over time
even so
you you don't even get to rest on your
laurels at any point you should always
be evaluating your processes and
determining whether you can
can make them better
these are all lessons i've learned from
the world of devops and when i say
devops i don't mean like the tools that
you find when you google what is devops
i mean like the philosophy of devops
teams working together
to
accomplish goals inside of an
organization
and
one of the really interesting i think
uh
tactical
metrics that spoke to me when i did a
deep dive on devops was
the idea of code deployment lead time
and this is
this is something that i've i've never
bothered trying to measure in my own
life but i i've realized that
i was
um
as i
have been on different teams trying to
accomplish goals and projects
almost subconsciously measuring like
how long does it take us to accomplish
this thing how long does it take us from
going from raw materials point a
to some kind of finished product and
when i feel like that time is like
growing
whereas it's taking too long it starts
to grate
on me like in my heart in
my core being
it eats away at me
and and that's what um
i think makes me a natural
uh analytic administrator makes me a
champion because i
am very bothered by these types of
problems
so
both of these questions are really
interesting to ask yourself if you
haven't
how long does it take you to get from
raw materials to a finished product
is that something you measure or is it
something that you just
intuit
and eats away at you and how many teams
do you have to traverse to make real
impact
with the product of your work that's
another really interesting one it may or
may not be relevant to you
but
also very relevant to the world of
devops philosophy
why does this matter
your analytic infrastructure is what
enables you or teams to deliver value
through decreasing that code deployment
lead time and it also
dominates how your daily work is
performed but these are like
pretty obvious
uh lessons i think um
this author jean kim has written a
number of really influential books in
the devops space two of which are novels
about i.t and death
one is called the phoenix phoenix
project and one
is the
unicorn project
and um
i've enjoyed both of them if you want to
read a really corny novel about it and
devops i highly recommend it
um
this quote is from him improving daily
work is even more important than doing
daily work
and so
if you don't have the tools you need to
accomplish
the data science daily work that you're
doing if you are
doing things in spreadsheets that take
days instead of
what you could automate
in
minutes or even seconds
um
it's affecting you it's affecting your
team it's affecting your organization's
bottom line
and so taking the time and energy to
advocate for better processes
is
in fact more important in those cases
than doing the daily work of those tasks
and
moving your spreadsheets around from
place to place and that's just an
example but it's something for my real
life i have spent
days and days and hours and hours
doing things inside of spreadsheets that
could be automated and it's really
interesting because i you know like i
have a really high tolerance
actually for doing that sort of stuff
even though i said like it does crush my
soul
at a certain point but in another you
know like i find it very meditative to
work inside of spreadsheets i don't have
anything against spreadsheets but
but there is like
also this power
and
like
real importance to
advocating for
process automation and
getting to the point where you can see
and
make the business case for the
importance of
automating basic processes
um
and so i've got
i've i've had a lot of success in my own
career doing that sort of advocacy and
work
um but it does it does sometimes
come at the cost of then realizing the
type of organization that you're a part
of
this gene kim in the unicorn project
wrote really
you know like this these stories are
both the same both the phoenix project
and the unicorn project they're both
like
like
very fun because they start inside of
organizations that are somewhere between
bureaucratic and a little bit
pathological and so
and then they they build out from that
you watch these characters like crawl
their way
back out of these organizations and like
build a better
future for themselves
and so i read the unicorn project i
probably in
whenever it came out in 2020 or 2019
um
this
this captures like this really visceral
feeling that i'm talking about in this
scene the main character maxine is a
developer and she's trying to improve
how development work is done
on her project in this like crucial
critical way but everything she tries
fails and like
every bit of
progress she makes seems
impossible and she's like
at her wit's end and i'll do a dramatic
reading she buries her head in her hands
and silently screams down keyboard
um
if you are looking for
some sort of like
catharsis
uh i highly recommend this book um
and the phoenix phoenix is the most
important project
in the company they've spent 20 million
over three years and yet here she is
trying to help and they won't spend five
hundred five thousand dollars on more
disk space and now she won't get a
development environment for five months
if you ever felt like you have been in
this scenario then
read this book and feel better
but also come to
this group because this is who we all
are we're we're this type of person
we've experienced this type of pain
and
um nathan stevens my old boss here at
our studio who has now since moved on um
to bigger better roles maybe um we're
sad to see him go but um
he
wrote very eloquently about
analytic administration and the type of
role that this person
at the time we called it the r admin
inhabited now we're more
more language inclusive we can we can
open it up to r and python admins or
data science admins in general but it's
a data scientist who
onboards new tools deploys solutions
supports existing standards works
closely with it to maintain upgrade and
scale analytic environments
influences other organizations others in
the organization to be more effective
and who is passionate about making
data science a legitimate analytic
standard within the organization
i really like uh this
um
this definition of who
we are in this space because uh it feels
very powerful and
it really spoke to me this is one of the
reasons this this type of of
thought leadership that nathan was was
writing at the time as one of the
reasons why i joined our studio the
solutions and sharing group um because i
i felt like a real sense of community
here and that's what i hope that we can
chat about today so
um i'll open it up to the group from
here but i i wanted to
leave this as sort of like
here are some of the challenges that i
see for analytic administrators in this
space
and i
typically break them out in different
talks and into organizational
challenges and technical challenges on
the organizational side like we've
talked about or been talking about
there's like
the question of credibility and
legitimacy
do you have that uh are you able to
advocate inside your organization from a
credible and legitimate place
do you have the right
leverage points or business cases built
out
to support you
and the cases that you're trying to
build and asking for the tools that you
need do you have the right relationships
have you built out a functional working
relationship with i.t
and how do you go about doing that and
then on the technical side are there
places where you feel as an analytic
admin or you don't even feel like you're
ready to take on the mantle of that
title yet maybe you need some more
technical skills experience education or
exposure in order to get to that level
and so across these topics especially i
would love to know how
we could support each other as
a community how our studio
can support you as well
and
i think
i love this site
especially the building a business case
uh section of the champions site if you
haven't checked it out at our studio.com
champion
um i know rachel had a big hand in
putting this together as well as i'm
sure a bunch of other people and i'm
sure some some folks on this call and
some customers
who have helped us out in a huge way in
pulling this information together
this section in particular on how to
build a business case and the playbook
for that
is really powerful um so i recommend
starting here especially if you're not
sure
where to get started or ideas for how to
get conversations rolling like you need
to first and foremost come to the table
with
some sort of ask some sort of plan and
and this is a really great framework for
thinking about how to start building
that
so i will stop talking sorry
once i get rolling i just
keep going
that was great thank you so much kelly
we were just saying in the chat when you
were showing the image from the plumber
hex sticker i always equate that to you
because i first saw that hex image from
at a women in data science conference
and it's when i met you
this is funny to see it there too um
just a reminder to everyone that you can
ask questions on
slido as well if you wanted to ask
anything um anonymously but i am gonna
stop the recording
now just so that everybody can feel free
to just jump in to the conversation as
well
um but for people watching the recording
thank you
[Music]
you